When Elon Musk’s first wife Justine
replied to a question on Quora
about how someone can be as great as Elon
or other super successful people, she wrote:
“These people tend to be freaks and misfits
who were forced to experience the
world in an unusually challenging way.”
Elon Musk grew up in Pretoria, South Africa and
said he had an unhappy and lonely childhood.
He didn’t spend much time playing with other kids.
Because he has Asperger’s, he struggled to pick
up social cues and to understand that sometimes,
people didn’t say exactly what they
meant but instead, spoke figuratively.
He only started to figure it out by immersing
himself in books and watching movies.
Musk even mused that perhaps he read too many
comics as a kid, telling Ashlee Vance in his
2015 book about him, “In the comics, it always
seems like they are trying to save the world.
It seemed like one should try to make the world a
better place because the inverse makes no sense.”
It’s no coincidence Musk has made it
his mission to make a mark on the world
with self-driving electric cars
and plans to colonize Mars.
His brilliance shown at an early age.
His father Errol once said that when
Elon was three or four years old,
his son asked him: “Where is the whole world?”
In other words, where did the world sit
in the grand scheme of the universe?
He endured years of ruthless bullying
as detailed in Ashlee Vance’s book.
One day in eighth or ninth grade, Musk recalled
how he and his brother Kimbal were sitting on
the top of a flight of stairs eating when a boy
snuck up behind him, kicked him in the head,
and shoved him down the stairs before a
bunch of boys beat him until he blacked out.
The beating damaged his nose so
badly it restricted the airflow
for which he later had surgery.
The bullies even beat up Musk’s best friend
until he agreed to stop hanging out with him.
Musk recalled in Vance’s book: “Moreover, they
got him—they got my best f*cking friend—to
lure me out of hiding so they could
beat me up. And that f*cking hurt.”
Vance described how: While telling this part of
the story, Musk’s eyes welled up and his voice
quivered. “For some reason, they decided
that I was it, and they were going to go
after me nonstop. That’s what made growing
up difficult. For a number of years, there
was no respite. You get chased around by gangs
at school who tried to beat the sh*t out of me,
and then I’d come home, and it would just be awful
there as well. It was just like nonstop horrible.”
Elon’s mother Maye and Errol
divorced when he was eight.
Maye said she left an abusive relationship.
She ran away with the three children,
and it was a struggle raising them as a single
mom. The model and nutritionist saved up what she
had and when money got tight, she fed the
kids peanut butter sandwiches and bean soup.
Elon eventually chose to live
with his father for a while
as he felt bad that his dad was living alone.
One has to wonder if Elon regretted that decision,
as he told Rolling Stone: “He
was such a terrible human being.
You have no idea. My dad will have a carefully
thought-out plan of evil. He will plan evil.”
I went into detail in another video about
Elon’s relationship with his father
which I’ll link in the description.
In response to Elon’s portrayal of
him, Errol Musk told Rolling Stone:
“I’ve been accused of being a Gay, a
Misogynist, a Paedophile, a Traitor,
a Rat, a Sh*t (quite often), a Bastard (by
many women whose attentions I did not return)
and much more. My own (wonderful) mother
told me I am ‘ruthless’ and should learn to
be more ‘humane.'” But, he concluded, “I love my
children and would readily do whatever for them.
Elon found comfort in coding.
By the time he was twelve, he coded a
space-themed video game called Blastar.
A South African magazine published
the source code and gave him $500.
The game was by no means a
marvel of computer programming,
but it did hint at the
genius brewing inside of him.
He would turn his science
fiction fantasies into reality
when he founded SpaceX at
the age of thirty, in 2002.
His enthusiasm to explore space also has roots in
the existential crisis he suffered as a teenager.
He studied religious texts
to learn the meaning of life.
He ended up embracing the lessons in The
Hitchhiker’s Guide to the Galaxy by Douglas Adams,
in which Musk says the lesson is
figuring out what questions to ask,
and then, the answer will be relatively simple.
Musk has said his aim is to increase the scope
and scale of human civilization, so that we’ll
learn more, become more enlightened, and are
better able to understand what questions to ask.
The boy who fantasized about
space and found solace in coding
would later learn to fight
back against his bullies.
He went through a growth spurt and by the time
he was 16, he was a towering six feet tall.
He also trained in karate, judo, and
wrestling and as he told Rolling Stone:
“I started dishing it out as
hard as they’d give it to me.”
When he knocked out the biggest
bully in school with one punch,
he noticed that the bully
never picked on him again.
He told the magazine: “It taught me a lesson:
If you’re fighting a bully, you cannot appease
a bully. You punch the bully in the nose.”
And perhaps that mentality shaped Elon Musk as
he had to fight to keep Tesla and SpaceX alive
even when the odds were heavily against him.
He also had to fight to prove his father wrong.
When Elon decided to move to Canada at
the age of 17, his mother’s birth country,
and later relocated here to Toronto, he
says his dad didn’t think he could make it,
and told him he’d be back in South Africa within
months. And that he was an idiot for trying.
He did two years of his undergrad
at Queen’s University in Kingston,
three hours drive east of Toronto. But
the goal was always to get to America.
After two years at Queen’s, he
transferred to the University
of Pennsylvania, his ticket to the promised land.
As a young boy growing up in South Africa
when apartheid was in its final years
but there was still tension
and violence, he saw America
as the land of opportunity. For
him, it was more than a cliché.
It was the one place where a lonely,
quiet kid with a talent for computers
could make something of himself.
No one could have predicted that he’d
become one of modern America’s greatest
industrialists - and perhaps, arguably,
the greatest entrepreneur of all time.
Elon Musk is a supremely talented engineer.
If you’d like to strive to become like Musk,
or simply want to improve your computer
science skills, my sponsor Brilliant is
an incredible way to learn STEM interactively.
Their “Computer Science Fundamentals” course
is perfect for you if you’d like to learn
the fundamentals of computer science
or strengthen your knowledge of core computer
science concepts, and no coding is required.
If you’d like to dig deeper and learn
more about artificial intelligence,
their Introduction to Neural Networks
course is a great way to learn about data
processing machines by experimenting hands-on.
My personal favorite are the Logic courses that
really improve your critical thinking skills.
There are no tests on Brilliant. And if you ever
get stuck, you can read the explanation for more.
Brilliant is FREE to try out if you head to the
link in my description or pinned
comment: brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 of you to click on my link
will get 20% off the Premium subscription which
gives you access to all of their offerings.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.